Mark Hamill: It’s hard to promote [the movie
BRIGSBY BEAR] without being able to be specific…
Film Courage: Yeah…I know.
Mark Hamill: It’s my fondest hope that people
will go because the best way to see it is
completely cold without any preconceived notions.
And I got to see [this movie] in Sundance
with an audience which is always exciting.
Because if you go to a studio screening everybody’s
predisposed to really like it.
Here was an audience that was really honest
and then the reaction was wonderful.
Film Courage: Well I’m wondering if we can
role play for a moment actually?
Kyle Mooney: Oh…wow?
Film Courage: Just a quick role play.
Kyle Mooney: Okay?
Yeah…I’m listening…
Film Courage: It will be PG.
It will be totally PG-13.
Kyle Mooney: Okay.
Film Courage: We won’t offend anyone or
anything like that.
Can you practice or show us sort of how you
pitched Mark Hamill the script [for BRIGSBY
BEAR] without giving away the incredible premise.
I know this is the tough part.
Mark Hamill: You didn’t have to!
Kyle Mooney: The Hollywood thing is there
are people who are doing all of these things
kind of for you.
Like we wrote the script and then our producers
(I imagine) got it in the hands of either
your daughter or your representation?
Mark Hamill: Probably my daughter.
Kyle Mooney: And then you had a chance to
read it.Mark Hamill: She runs everything.
I don’t know what’s going on.
Kyle Mooney: We were fortunate in that one
of our producers is friends with Chelsea so…
Mark Hamill: Is that right?
Kyle Mooney: Right?
That is correct.
She’s over here [points off camera].
Film Courage: Oh!
Great choice.
Awesome choice!
Kyle Mooney: But we can still do the role
play!
Film Courage: Okay!
Let’s do it.
Kyle Mooney: Here…here’s what it would
have been like “Hey, Bill over at Lonely
Island, can you get this…or Will over at
Lord and Miller, can you get this script over
to Chelsea Hamel to potentially get it to
Mark Hamill?”
“We will do our best!”
“Okay, thank you!”
And I imagine you get a phone call or an email…
Mark Hamill: “Send me a deal memo!
I don’t care about the script.
I just want to know how much I can make!
Do I get any back-end?”
Believe me, at this point in my career, the
script is everything.
I was saying to Kyle earlier, I don’t even
know how much I made for this movie because
once I like something and you factor in that
they don’t have a huge budget.
That’s what I love about this.
George [Lucas] called STAR WARS the most expensive
low-budget movie ever made.
Kyle Mooney: And which George?
Mark Hamill: Oh, he’s retired now but his
point was that all the money is up on the
screen.
The only place they had to pay real money
to were Sir Alec Guinness and Peter Cushing
because we were all pretty much unknowns.
And with this I was set up in the wrong way
because it’s called BRIGSBY BEAR and it’s
co-written by Kyle Mooney [and Kevin Costello]
and it’s directed by the Saturday Night
Live guy [Dave McCary] and Andy Samberg is
connected and Beck Bennett and Michaela Watkins,
so I was expecting these people.
So I was expecting this broad, over-the-top
comedy and it was so unexpected.
I loved it from the first time I read it.
Film Courage: Did the character of Ted take
any convincing [for you to want to portray]?
Because I know he is a complicated person
(again without trying to give away too much
information).
But I think I had read something in the press
notes Mark that you said that he’s the kind
of character that you’d rather watch than
play.
I mean there is a lot of layers to him.
Mark Hamill: Yeah.
He’s dark.
Well again, it wasn't from the standpoint
that I have to play a character that everyone
admires.
You know, I love playing villainous roles
but no villain ever thinks of themselves as
evil.
They did the right thing in their estimation.
But there is no getting around he did something
that terrifies any parent.
That’s like their worst fear.
But again, that wasn’t so important in the
larger scheme of things.
I was just trying to understand a person that
would do that.
And I think Jane Adams who plays my wife does
a lot in making you understand their relationship
and how controlling and aggressive she is.
But she brings a lot more to the table than
the script so we were really lucky to have
her.
Film Courage: Kyle are you aware of how other
people who are fan obsessed are going to relate
to this film because it shows such a great…I
mean it’s an original story but it’s also
sort of a wonderful tribute to you and all
of your Good Neighbor (Youtube Sketch Comedy
Group) on being obsessed and making something.
Wondering if you can talk about that?
Kyle Mooney: Well…I’m an obsessive person
and I’ve had so many obsessions throughout
my life.
Star Wars being one of them at one point.
And yeah it’s true there are people that
love our videos and followed us for so long
and I hope they come along to see this because…it’s
not necessarily what those videos are, it’s
different.
But in terms of obsession and fandom, what
you see on screen is the way a lot of us feel.
We have such a strong connection to these
TV shows or movies or music and it’s not
always a terrible thing.
In the case of this movie, [Kyle’s character
protaganist James Pope] love for Brigsby Bear
kind of unites him and his friends and his
family and they make this thing together.
Mark Hamill: You never outgrew….you out
grow these things, right?
You said “There was a point where I liked
STAR WARS” because basically our fans are
the young and the mentally young.
Kyle Mooney: No.
My point is I’ve never outgrown STAR WARS.
My point was there was a specific time where
I was probably the most obsessed about it.
Now it’s turned into a minor obsession.
Mark Hamill: [Laughs] Okay.
Just checking.
It’s okay.
I mean people come up and say “I’m really
sorry I’ve never seen STAR WARS.”
Well, that’s fine!
I’m not upset.
That’s okay.
It’s not for everybody, you know.
Like I said, the young and the mentally young.
Those are the ones that are really our biggest
fans.
There is something to be said about it appeals
to the child in all of us because you see
grown men, policemen and firemen who are authority
figures let down their guard and become 9-years-old
again.
Like “Will you pose with this lightsaber?”
“Really!?
You were just about to arrest me.
Now you’re my friend?”
It’s been amazing because I never expected
it to have this longevity or the impact on
these people.
And you meet people all the time that say
“I became what I became because of that
movie.”
So it’s quite…it’s awesome when you
think of the impact that it’s had after
all these years.
I certainly never thought I’d still be talking
about it.
Kyle Mooney: And that’s what we’re trying
to do with BRIGSBY BEAR.
Mark Hamill: And I think you’re well on
your way because it is like a valentine to
obsessed compulsives, you know?
You’re saying it’s okay to be this way.
I love the fact that James is so accepted
by the teenagers you’ll think ‘Well gosh
someone that innocent, you know he is almost
like Rip Van Winkle where he wakes up in a
world he never made.
I love the scene with the teenage party they’re
having and he doesn’t know all of the vernacular
(he’s using some of the slang wrong).
And instead of being cynical and ostracizing
and making fun of him, he’s accepted.
I mean it’s charming, it really is.